[Music]
perfect timing I need to go downtown and
get me snacks for Tim Duncan happy the
games starting here faster than delivery
with the hopes thing now remember it's
for Tim Duncan so nothing fancy just the
fundamentals come on let's go
I'm expecting change you guys are really
zeroing out my night just gonna watch
the game I think I know that guy Wow
look at that new guy who's that that's
my cue I gotta go find Captain America I
stole his shield up threw it at him with
swords amazing things ever happen to
mrs. Oakes like a ruse and I just sort
of flipped in hey geez a second coming
hey Nathan Walsall the rich and the
powerful I don't care about us with pick
up after we think their table scraps
these alien bastards it tough you got to
use the stuff they use the world's
change timely change to play Sonic
retreat next mission will call you kick
it a little more men touring be real-ass
six the team that's not a hug I'm just
grabbing the tow for you oh all right
kid good luck out there someone is
collecting stuff from Avengers battles
and building these crazy weapons this is
my chance to prove myself
what if somebody had died to different
story right cuz that's on you I wanted
you to be better eight years without in
trouble from those bozos up in stark
tower and it's no bastard red tide shows
of Bob
he thinks he can tear down everything
I've built
Plane full of brand-new Avengers
weaponry to load up
we're going to put him out of business
we're gonna take everything they got
[Music]
do you know him - yeah still issue
[Music]